it would be impossible to sum up what
these protests were about
in britain in france italy greece
australia
people from all walks of life threw
caution to the wind
in a bid to be heard to cry out
and the one thing that they all wanted
is to say
we're tired tired and angry
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
one's first thought may be that this
isn't very smart staging a mass protest
in the middle of a pandemic
worse while the delta variant so much
more contagious is
making the rounds and that is what
australian leaders for example
latched on to calling protesters morons
in relation to yesterday's protest uh
can i say how absolutely disgusted i was
it broke my heart millions and millions
of people across our state are doing the
right thing
and it just broke my heart that people
had such a disregard
for their fellow citizens what we saw
today in sydney
is unfortunately something that we've
seen in cities that we
all shake our heads at it's quite clear
that you know
sydney isn't immune from morons as well
except of course it isn't that simple
people are weary they are fatigued by
this pandemic the bad news the the
lockdowns the isolation
all over the world in that respect we're
all the same
people yearn for freedoms and
equality we are not against vaccines as
they claim
this is not an anti-vaccination movement
these are thinking people who want
freedom
i believe that this is an attack on
fundamental freedoms in france there is
a law saying medical procedures cannot
be forced
since vaccination is being imposed on us
one way or another
the people behind the health passport
are behaving like nazis
we are forced to get vaccinated we no
longer have freedom of choice
as we must obey the government which in
my opinion
is tyrannical despotic and absolutely
illegitimate
public irritation morphs into anger even
rage
and even lunacy are the european
the doctors and nurses stood trial and
they
hung some
go too far way too far they never
consider the other side of the argument
the
millions and millions that have been
killed killed by this virus
that is indisputable and leaders have
one
overarching goal to prevent millions
more from
sharing the same fate and they have
decided that personal
freedoms over which europeans fought
wars
that those freedoms can be suspended
the world is facing a fourth wave and we
must act
and at the same time we know the key to
this problem it's not new
the contagiousness of this delta variant
is forcing us to do more
we must vaccinate the bitter truth is
that there is no miracle solution
not one that will make everyone happy no
matter how many
protests people stage you no matter how
many lockdowns governments implement
the very best we can hope for are
civility
and perseverance which will probably
require protesters to
refrain from trying to hang doctors and
officials to decease
from calling voters morons
you